bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors quatre
rassemblements à paris iii à
l'initiative des jd jaune qu'est ce que
vous demandez aujourd'hui
écoutez c'est simple aussi c'est ce que
nous demanderons depuis maintenant plus
de deux ans c'est à dire le
immédiatement des mesures d'urgence sur
le plan social des mesures sur le plan
environnemental la convention climat n'a
reçu aucun recul satisfaction ensuite
des mesures démocratiques et des mesures
fiscales notamment le rétablissement de
l'impôt sur la fortune
et depuis c'est d'ajouter une autre
revendication très importante qui est
celle du rétablissement des libertés
liberté de manifester en sécurité
liberté de circuler liberté à tous
points de vue au plan personnel
puisqu'aujourd'hui la circulation des
personnes commencent à être limité et on
voit encore les dernières mesures des
ressorts prise par le premier ministre
qui sont encore une aggravation de ses
liberté de circuler et on voit bien que
le gouvernement 30 prétexte de la crise
sanitaire qui existent que personne n'a
ni évidemment pour museler encore plus
le peuple est pourquoi il fait sorte
parce que certains disent oui il a
inventé non non non il invente rien il
utilise la crise sanitaire pour essayer
de se sortir des difficultés dans
lesquelles il était entré avant la crise
sanitaire
c'est à dire que le mouvement de
protestation contre les retraites le
mouvement des gilets jaunes des
mouvements sur l'environnement commencé
à se rassembler et donc le gouvernement
prend peur et il sait très bien que
quand on va sortir de cette crise
sanitaire les problèmes seront encore
plus accrue il faudra donc des réponses
positives et il est incapable de les
fournir
ce qu'on ne peut pas à la fois
satisfaire les dividendes des
actionnaires et satisfaire les intérêts
de l'ensemble de la population
c'est inconciliables voilà pourquoi les
problèmes de liberté sont posées et on
va voir parce qu'on le voit maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois
décret après décret projet de loi
appelée projet de loi on voit que ce
régime ce cycle est en plein de soucis
fier sur des de se rétracter sur les
problèmes de liberté tout court
alors j'ai encore appris que cette nuit
des jeunes eux qui avaient fait une
petite fiesta ont été encore sanctionnés
et donc tout cela ne va pas dans le sens
d'une vie libre et démocratique pour
tous or c'est ce qu'il nous faut
aujourd'hui parce que penser quand
vaincre à la crise sanitaire par brimer
les gens complètement inconcevable
ces fûts il faut maintenant développer
la participation des gens 1la leur prise
de décision à leur vie il faut que ce
soit que nous ce que nous soyons les
acteurs de notre vie monsieur espinosa
si on devait faire un bilan parce que le
mouvement des gels et jaune est né en
2018 ça fait plusieurs années maintenant
est ce que vous diriez que vos
revendications sont les mêmes
aujourd'hui les revendications sont les
mêmes et nous ont pris une acuité plus
grande
je prends par exemple le au plan social
il fallait relever massivement le smic
et les minima sociaux
mais aujourd'hui c'est encore plus vrai
puisque avec le chômage partiel les
salariés on veut diminuer de 16% leur
pouvoir d'achat et demi qu il faut
maintenant prendre des mesures encore
plus grande et je crois que c'est ce qui
fonde le fait que des millions de gens
le traduisent alors à leur façon ils ne
sont pas tous
les jaunes mais ils sont tous demandent
de revendication forte
je prends par exemple les gens qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux et dans le
secteur hospitalier et dans le secteur
de la santé en général
eh bien il faut là aussi une
revalorisation forte de pouvoir avoir
une attractivité pour les jeunes pour
qu'ils deviennent des acteurs de notre
système sanitaire qui a bien besoin
d'être redressées puisqu'aujourd'hui on
le voit nous avons reculé au niveau
mondial ce qui est une aberration totale
alors que nous nous sommes le pays qui
formons les chercheurs les plus avancées
ils ce sont les autres pays qui nous les
achète et qui nous les prennent note
europe
josé espinosa rebelles vous êtes gilet
jaune merci d'avoir été en direct sur
arte france d'avoir a répondu à nos
questions marciac et bien je vous
remercie